[TITLE MUSIC PLAYING]
JAGAN CUDDAPAH: My
name is Jagan Cuddapah
I'm a technical account
manager within Google Cloud.
I work with financial
services customers primarily.
And as a technical
account manager,
my job is to make sure
that my customers are
happy with everything
that happens in the cloud.
I do this through a variety
of different things.
One of the things
that I focus on
is high-performance computing.
And today, we're going
to talk a little bit more
about what that means for
Professional Services, what
that means for you.
ERIC POON: Hey guys, I'm Eric,
strategic cloud engineer,
also working on
financial services
and high-performance computing
with Google Cloud as part
of the Professional
Services Organization.
We do help our largest and
most interesting customers
and partners get there.
JAGAN CUDDAPAH: Yeah, so
before we get started--
we have a pretty good agenda
planned for you today.
Before we get
started, I just wanted
to give you a little
bit of flavor of what is
Google Professional Services.
We obviously go by an
acronym, called PSO.
But the idea is, our mission
is to help you get the most
out of Google products.
As you can see, there's a lot
of announcements that come out
from Google, there's
a lot of things
that you can potentially
do, and there
are a lot of different
products you can use.
Our job, as
Professional Services,
is to help you put together
all these products in some sort
of coherent story, and help you
get the best out of the Google
product system.
I wanted to give you that
flavor before we go in,
but most of the session
is going to cover a lot
about how we can help you.
In terms of agenda, we want to
talk about five things today.
1 is, why HPC on GCP?
2 is, how you can do this.
We have some blueprints for you.
3 is, then, we're going to
tell you how we can help you,
we as Professional Services.
And then we actually
have a customer
that we've done this with who's
going to come up here and talk
about their experience with us.
And then we are also going
to show you what exactly we
do with customers.
So we have some folks here.
Our engagement leader is
going to do this work.
So it will be a fun session.
We have about 50 minutes.
So we'll go through
as much as we can,
and please feel free to ask
a few questions at the end.
Thank you.
ERIC POON: Thanks, Jagan.
So first and foremost, why HPC,
and why do we run it on GCP?
Well, you guys already know why
you need to have HPC workloads.
We're here to tell you
why do you want it on GCP.
But just a little
bit of recap anyway.
Compute needs are growing.
And I don't think it's
a surprise to anyone
that it's growing in this way.
Here's a growth chart of
the top 500 supercomputers,
with the sum of the list
now exceeding one exaflop,
and exascale systems are
actually on their way.
So while these are
the leading systems,
the rest of the HPC
industry follows along
with the same trends.
And on the data side--
not just compute side,
right, with HPC, we
also talk about data.
"Big data," we've been using
that term for a long time.
10 years ago, when we had
3-petabyte-capacity systems,
we called that big data.
Now we're at
250-petabytes-capacity systems,
10 years later, and we're
still calling that big data.
So big data is actually
bigger than big.
And the third variable in all
this, it's also expensive.
Look at all those numbers on
that timeline on the left side.
And running on-prem, we
also have that limitation
of how we can consume.
The time that we
need our workloads
to run and be processed
is not really predictable.
Sometimes it's bursty.
And with on-prem,
with 100%, we're
really forced to wait
when we get to this area.
If I run out of compute and
I have to put more things in,
I have to wait until
it's available.
And when I don't have
a lot of things to run,
I'm wasting money
because I still
have to pay for that power
to run my on-prem systems.
So running it in the cloud
is a pretty good idea
in our opinion.
But what are the
key differentiators
for Google, and why do
we want to run on Google?
Compute storage and networking,
those three main things.
On the compute side of things,
as you guys all probably know,
how many of you know
that we have what
we call preemptible VMs?
These are VMs that
we haven't sold yet,
and we're like, well,
they're sitting there anyway,
why don't we give it
to you at a discount?
They're super-low cost and
they're short-term instances.
And in order to
make sure that you
don't use those preemptible
VMs in a bad way,
we actually say,
you know what, we're
going to preempt them
at least once every day.
This way, you don't get used to
having preemptible VMs running
long term and then, all
of a sudden, they go away.
But what's coming up?
What's new?
We do have some new VM families
that are available in the AP,
and that's
compute-optimized VMs.
Anyone interested in
Cascade Lake processors?
3.8 gigahertz, right?
That's coming in
compute-optimized VMs.
You just heard that
announced during Next today.
We have memory-optimized VMs.
This way, we can
actually have 6 terabyte
and 12 terabyte memory attached
to VMs in your processing
nodes.
So this is the exciting
part of what's coming.
So if we look at, across the
board, of what we've already
brought a while ago--
custom machine types,
what we brought a
while ago, preemptible
VMs, quick, point-to-point
VM-to-VM networks.
And tomorrow, we are bringing
compute-optimized VMs.
We're bringing native job
scheduler integrations,
sole tenant nodes for those
chatty workloads that you have,
and most importantly, bringing
all of this from VM clusters
to Kubernetes.
All of this is
coming technology.
Storage is also a thing.
Most of the time, when
you are running on-prem,
you're talking about
different data stores.
They typically evolve around a
shared file system or other--
what else is there?
What else do you guys
run on-prem for storage?
Lustre, Elastifile.
We are partnering with all
of these different vendors
out there--
storage vendors-- to bring you a
good storage ecosystem as well.
And later, we'll see a whole
slide of those partners.
And last but not least,
the network on GCP.
We have a fast network.
We have 16 terabit
cross-section network bandwidth
inside our data centers.
And you can actually have
up to 7,000 VMs per VPC.
There's predictable
latency across any node
across the globe.
And each VM can
actually take advantage
of 16 gigabits of throughput.
So this is our ecosystem.
Between storage, workload
managers, HPC applications,
and solutions
integrators that can
help you get your workload
there, I believe HPC on GCP
is the way to go.
Feel free to take
a picture of this
as well for a link to any of
the other sessions that are
HPC-related here at Next 2019.
So now we know why, but how?
How do we do it?
Well, what are some of the
blueprints that we have?
What are the common
patterns that we
see HPC customers using on GCP?
Burst to cloud-- you
can do auto-scaling.
I don't always need to
have a static cluster
of a certain size.
And if I am streaming
input to my workload,
I can actually have that cluster
grow and shrink as needed,
so I am paying for only
the compute that I need,
and not a cent more.
We can actually also federate
your compute workload
to the cloud only.
Running in this way over
VPN or interconnects,
you can actually
have your schedulers
and your worker nodes
on-prem, and only when
your on-prem
hardware is exhausted
and you need to go faster do
we need to go to the cloud.
So this is another
pattern that we see.
So putting it all together,
we have a lot of things here.
Number one, we
see external feeds
and cloud Pub/Sub as an
example of a streaming input
to Cloud Storage.
And Cloud Storage is our
product where we really
stage all the inputs and the big
data to be used in these jobs.
That goes in to your HPC farm.
On Compute Engine,
you can actually
have GPUs, TPUs,
as well as CPUs.
And this is the part
that we're talking about.
This is the part that
can scale up and down
and run compute
optimized, et cetera.
The rest of the diagram
that you see here
are really integrations
with other things.
So if you take a
look at number 4,
after the HPC perform
processes everything
and it puts it back
into a big storage area,
we're going to once again make
use of Google Cloud Storage.
And from there, you can actually
hook that up to BigQuery,
put that in archival
storage and code line,
use that to train ML
models in TensorFlow.
When you run HPC on GCP, the
entire ecosystem opens to you,
and that's what
we're talking about.
With that said, how can
we help you get there?
JAGAN CUDDAPAH: Thanks, Eric.
So as you saw in the last slide,
we have a lot of products.
And I had mentioned earlier on
that the Google ecosystem is
constantly growing.
It's great, and it's also
challenging in the perspective
that you have to learn a lot
of new things on the fly,
basically at all times,
which is a good thing.
But when you try to
build a solution,
it sort of gets
overwhelming so we,
at Google professional
services, sort of
believe in building with you.
The idea is that our HPC SMEs--
some of them are
with you right now,
our consultants who
you're going to hear from,
and cloud engineers
like Eric himself--
we will work with you
to build this out.
The idea is not like
other consulting firms,
wherein we just come in, and
we just do stuff and go away.
We believe in this thing
called crawl, walk, run.
It's a well-understood
term in the industry.
But basically the idea
is, pace yourself,
as opposed to try
to do-- everybody
wants to do something radical.
Everybody wants to do something
really cool and innovative.
But we want to try to get
something practical done first,
and then you sort of
go to the next step.
So from an HPC
perspective, what we
have done with other
customers where
we've been quite successful
is, first we come in
and we do some sort
of questionnaire,
and we work with
your HPC engineers
to understand the
current state-- what
batch schedulers do you
have, what storage systems
do you use?
Then we try to
understand what that
means, like what do you want
to change in six months?
Then we develop a
target state for you.
And then we actually
work with you
to build a proof of concept.
This is a pretty
interesting exercise,
and I'll talk to you
a little bit more
about it in the
next slide, but it's
when Google engineers
actually sit down
with your HPC staff
and your business folks
and we work with you to
deploy your workload on GCP--
how to set up the network,
how to configure IM policies.
There's a whole
bunch of stuff that
has to happen which we're
going to help you with.
The second piece
is when you walk.
Now that you know the POC and
you have confidence in it,
what you're really looking to
do is to actually deploy this.
So Google Professional
Services can
help, but we have a whole bunch
of partners, like ROs and GFD--
in the slide, you saw
that-- who will actually
do this work for you if you
don't have the bandwidth
to do this.
Typically we've seen
customers go either way.
If you want to do it, great.
If you don't want to do
it, then we have partners.
We can do it either ways.
And then the final state is run.
And this is where it gets
really exciting for customers.
Now that you are in the cloud
and you have this deployed,
how do you make the
best use of the cloud?
So the architecture that
Eric was showing you about
is cloud native.
But that's basically
the power of the cloud,
is you get to try all
these new products.
So with that, today, we are
launching a new service.
We call it the first part
of the journey, the crawl
part of the journey.
It's called Cloud Discover HPC.
This is a service
offering that we have been
piloting for the last one year.
We've been fairly
successful at it.
We've done it with a
financial services firm
that you'll hear from.
We've done it with
a health care firm.
We're doing it with another
big health care firm next week,
and we've done it with
[? 3Du. ?] We have
done about like 78 of these--
some with us, some
with our partners.
We've gotten pretty good
at it, I would think.
The idea is that, in the very
first week, what we're doing is
we do some prep work before
we get on the ground,
to understand what
your workload looks
like and all that good stuff.
Then we actually do
a whiteboarding--
then we come on site, on a
three-day effort, wherein
we sit down with you, we
do whiteboarding exercises
to figure out what
the target state is.
And as soon as
you do that, we're
actually in code
development mode.
We are actually getting our
hands dirty with your staff.
And the idea is that, in three
days, we want to build a POC.
And also it's not
like we do the work
and you sit out of the room.
We're actually sitting with you.
And the idea is, we
want to teach you
how to do this as
opposed to us do this.
Once this is done, we go
back, we understand what's
been done so far, then we put
together a technical design
document, which is
essentially a plan that says,
OK, now that this is the POC,
how do you take this POC,
and how do you take
it to the next level.
It's a pretty good
exercise, because what
we have seen
customers do is they
get their hands dirty with GCP
and all the different product
sets out there, as opposed to
just being a bunch of slides.
And the second thing is, you get
to work with real-life stuff,
which is always exciting.
I just described this to you,
but just to go back on that,
week 0 is very much
around preparation,
week 1 is planning, and then
week 2 is design for future.
One thing I definitely
want to call out is,
we've had a lot of
customers do this,
and the part that really excites
them is that when the business
comes up with a use case--
let's say bulk calculations are
getting slower, we need more
capacity, whatever it is--
this is a great
opportunity for your IT
to get involved as well.
And we actually
sit with your IT.
And in a lot of
enterprise organizations,
the business and IT
are two separate--
I don't want to say
silos, but they're
two different organizations
with two different priorities.
So this is one area where the
business has said something,
and within five days, you
can say, hey, we built a POC,
this works or this doesn't--
hopefully it works.
And we can say OK, now what?
So I know I've said a lot
about how good we are.
I think it'll be helpful
for you to hear from one
of our first customers.
So I'd like to call
on stage Naveed Malik.
He's the head of data
for Cubist Systematic.
He was one of our
first customers.
And Naveed will share the
good and the bad that we had.
NAVEED MALIK: Thank you, Jagan.
First of all, there are
glaring lights in front of me.
So if I'm not looking at
you, I'm not ignoring you,
I'm just trying to
avoid the lights.
So starting with the high-level
overview of our company,
Cubist Systematic is the
trading division of Point72.
And Point72 is one of the
legendary hedge funds, founded
by Steve Cohen in 1992.
The systematic business
was started early 2000s.
And the systematic business
is now called Cubist.
So when we talk about
data, any hedge fund
typically uses a lot of data.
But specifically, the
systematic hedge funds--
other names are like
black box trading,
or whatever you call it,
or quantitative trading--
they use massive
amounts of data,
because they need this data to
run their trading strategies,
because these are 100%
automated systems.
We started thinking about
HPC a few years ago.
At that time, Google Cloud
or Google HPC environment
was not at that level.
We tried a few
other options, which
is out-of-scope for
today's discussion.
But I'll talk a little
bit about where we went
and how we set it up.
So in general, any data
processing problem,
first of all, it is
going to be I/O bound.
So a lot of people
make the mistake
of throwing a lot
of codes at it.
It's not going to
solve the problem.
Because if you are
I/O bound, first you
need to solve the I/O problem--
I/O and network.
So the way we solve
the problem is
by building an in-house
HPC environment, which
utilizes a cluster-based
solution using cheap
magnetic disks with
SSDs for metadata,
and connected through
the InfiniBand fabric
to compute nodes.
And compute nodes are
running Condor grid.
So this environment works pretty
neat for our requirements.
Actually, at that time, when we
were building this environment
about three years ago,
we knew there are going
to be some bursty workloads.
We thought, OK, it will
take us a week to--
from time to time, to run
through those bursty workloads.
But for sustained workloads,
the in-house HPC was enough.
And sustained workloads are
what we had to do, day in
and day out, in terms
of processing the data
as well as delivering
the data to the clients.
And I'll have a little
bit more detail on that.
So question is, why did
we choose Google Cloud?
And actually, even more
fundamental question
is, why did we choose
to go for cloud?
So as I mentioned earlier,
the in-house HPC solution
was great for our
sustained workloads.
But the bursty workloads
that we thought
are going to be occasional
actually turned out
to be a lot more frequent.
It happens maybe once a
week, a few times a month,
where we have to go through
some massive amount of data
processing.
And that creates
a problem for us,
because in that time, first
of all, the users are waiting.
If a user has to wait for, say,
seven days to get their data,
that is an opportunity lost.
They could have done something
else during that time.
So to deal with
those situations,
we considered other options.
And then we decided
to run a complete POC
after getting an overview
of storage, and network,
and compute resources
provided by Google.
So that is--
So as I mentioned
earlier, when we
are talking about
HPC environments,
there are a few
fundamental components
that you have to worry about--
storage and network are
the most important one.
And I'm talking about
HPC for data processing.
There might be other situations
where you just need compute,
and you're good with it.
But for data
processing workloads,
you need to have
good storage which
can supply enough
data to your nodes,
and network, which
can deliver the data--
and compute, obviously.
But there are two
additional components,
which we were very conscious
about and I'm sure a lot of you
are going to be conscious.
They are cost and support.
So cost-- a lot of people
think that cloud is cheap.
But if you don't use
it in a sensible way,
it can become very expensive.
So we were very
cautious about the cost.
We wanted to be
sure, first of all,
how the storage is
going to perform,
how is the network
going to be, what
are the costs for the
compute, and overall,
what is the cost going to be?
And support-- in any kind
of compute environment,
you want to have
very good support.
So, speaking of support,
as Jagan mentioned earlier,
this PSO organization was great.
It was a fantastic team of
engineers and developers.
And Gabriele, in
his leadership, he
brought together
a really good team
which helped us set
up this environment.
So now I'll go a little bit into
more detail on the application
or the problem which was
for testing the Google HPC
environment.
So we chose to use one of the
problems, which is level 2 data
processing.
And specifically we chose CME.
This was just one of the
more established ones,
so we wanted to try that one.
In adaptive book processing,
you get massive amount
of data in terms of
updates to the book.
And every update to the
book results in a change
of the state of the book.
And more importantly,
every method
had to be processed in
a particular sequence.
So you have the option to--
the first logical thing is
maybe save the state of the book
every time there is a change.
The problem is there are a
large number of instruments,
and every instrument can tick
tens or hundreds of times
every millisecond.
So if you try to save the
book state at every update,
it will result in a
gigantic amount of data.
And there is nothing wrong
with gigantic amount of data.
The problem is, to
retrieve it, it's
going to be counterproductive.
In this case, CME is a 50
gigabyte compressed messages,
not a book state.
So compressed
messages, every day,
and we had to go through
12 years of history.
So what was the
business objective
of this particular application?
The business objective is to
be able to deliver book state
for any given instrument at any
given point in time in history.
So as I mentioned,
the messages have
to be processed in a
sequence, from the opening
time to the point in
time the user needs it.
So it is very expensive to
go through the whole days
of messages to build a state
for the given point in time.
So what we did is we ran
through the 12 years of history,
saved a snapshot of
the book every minute
boundary, and we have an
API which recreates the book
at any given point in time.
So the user requests,
for instrument ABC,
I need data as of
this timestamp--
for the book state
as of this timestamp.
It finds the previous
minute snapshot,
and applies the messages
during that minute,
and builds and
delivers the state.
It does a lot more
other things also
which are out-of-scope
for this discussion.
So doing this, the
result was we were
able to successfully duplicate
our environment in Google,
and not only duplicate, we were
able to test the scalability
also.
As I mentioned
earlier in the slides,
the first challenge is,
always, for data processing,
think about storage and network.
We were OK with that.
And then the
problem that we were
having being able to scale
up and down on demand,
that was resolved.
And we tested by spinning up 400
compute nodes in-house anytime
we are running from
20 to 30 nodes.
And we did some
experimentation and there is
some additional
experiments going on,
in terms of how much
we can push it--
can we run 1,000 and 2,000, and
how does the performance scale?
As like with any
successful test,
a good customer service
would ask for feedback.
And Jagan and Gabriele
asked me kind of definitely,
what should we improve, what
we could have done better.
So as I mentioned,
for any client,
cost is definitely one of
the factors to worry about.
And especially with
the preemptibles,
that's a great idea.
I love the idea.
The problem is,
it's hard to tell
how many preemptibles are going
to be available at any given
time.
So calculating costs becomes a
much more complicated problem.
You can hope there is going
to be low cost because
of preemptibles, but
you don't have an idea
of what it is going to be.
So coming from a
quantitative background,
my suggestion is to make
either the history available
or just use the history, run
some ML techniques on top of it
to kind of predict how many
preemptibles are going to get
utilized for a given problem.
So during the PSA,
we actually had
to run the batches to
see the actual cost--
like after running it, instead
of trying estimate it ahead
of time.
Although kudos to
Google for providing
an excellent dashboard
for looking at what
the cost is, where
the cost came from,
whether it came from storage,
network, or from compute.
And just so you know,
most of the cost
was coming from storage
because we wanted
a very high-throughput storage.
That's the end of
the presentation.
By the way, I'm around
if anybody has questions,
actually we have a question
and answer session at the end.
I just wanted to mention, I
am leading this Cubist Data
Services Group, and looking
for good data scientists,
software developers.
We are not looking for
hedge fund expertise.
Somebody is a good
C++ developer,
we are definitely
looking for them--
so Python and so on.
And not only my group.
There are many groups
within our organization
who are looking for
good technologists.
We are competing with
Google for talent.
[CHUCKLING]
So if you are interested
in working on--
staying in the technology,
working on high-tech area,
and at the same time learning
about financial industry,
there is an email address here--
cubisttalent@cub
istsystematic.com.
And also, you can
look my contact up
from the speaker profile.
So at this point,
I'll hand it over
to Gabriele, who I
mentioned was the lead Cloud
consultant and PSO.
He was instrumental in
making it a success.
Thank you so much.
GABRIELE GARZOGLIO: All
right, thank you Naveed.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, can we
switch to the demo?
All right, thanks a lot.
All right, in the
next 10 minutes or so,
I'm going to show you how
to deploy an HTCondor batch
scheduler in GCP.
So HTCondor is the
batch scheduler
that we deployed at Cubist, so
I thought it was a good example
to show you.
It's not the only scheduler
that we support in GCP.
There is Slurm, PBS,
there is a whole bunch.
What we will be doing
now, I will show you
how to deploy this using Google
Deployment Manager scripts.
So I'll show you where
to get these scripts,
how to launch them,
and then the scripts
will deploy what we call a
submit host, where you can
log in and submit your jobs.
There will be a
Central Manager that
will be used to
coordinate and match
the jobs to the resources.
Once I have showed you
how to deploy the cluster,
I will show you how to set up
auto-scaling for your cluster
with a solution that
will bring up nodes
or down depending on
the number of jobs that
are available in the queue.
So let's start.
First thing, I'm going
to get some software.
So I'll start from here.
It's software that you
can find in GitHub--
GCP and HTCondor.
So these are the
three words that you
need to find the software.
And look here,
I'm feeling lucky,
and the first hit
is my software.
Now, everything that
I'm going to show you
is actually explained in here.
So you can actually
redo it yourself.
But of course, I'm
going to show you now.
To get the software--
so this is GitHub.
You can go to the repository.
You can say, Clone, copy the
GitHub link into your memory,
and then you can say
git clone, and here.
This will bring the software
into your Cloud Shell
environment.
I'm showing you my
Cloud Shell environment.
I've created a project called
HTCondor Demo to do that.
And then of course,
since this is a demo,
I have already downloaded it.
And so I can go to
where the code is.
So this is the
software that we're
going to use to
provision the resources
and then run startup
scripts that will
install HP Condor in the nodes.
This is the main
piece of software
that you need to configure
to change the configuration
of your cluster.
It's the Condor cluster YAML.
So this is the list of
files that you have,
this is what you want to
change, and the parameters
are these ones.
You have the number
of nodes that you
want to have statically
located, then
you can scale them up and down.
The type of resources that
you want to provision.
In this case, I'm
provisioning nodes
with four calls each, CentOS.
And then Condor version
8.81, which is the latest.
I know this demo
works with this.
If you don't
specify the version,
you get the latest one.
So let's get down to it.
So to kick it off,
you use this command,
which was also explained
in the instructions
as I was showing
it to you before.
And this will take the
configuration from YAML
that we just changed and
deploy the resources.
You can see what
Google Cloud is doing
by going into your console.
And as you can see,
the Deployment Manager
is actually working to
deploy our resources.
You can see the details
of the resources which
are provisioning here.
Now we are deploying a network.
And as the network
is deployed, we'll
create some firewall
rules to allow
communication between the demos
on the nodes that we installed.
As I mentioned, there is
going to be a Master, a Submit
node, and then a bunch
of compute resources.
So while we wait
for this to spin up,
let me tell you a bit
more about what this is.
So I went fast over this before.
The two nodes that
you are deploying
is the Submit and
Central Manager.
But the compute
nodes we will deploy
using what we call a
Managed Instance Group.
Now, a Managed Instance
Group is a resource in GCP
that gives you the
ability of creating
multiple identical resources.
And so it provides
an interface, an API,
that allows you to specify
how many nodes of that kind
you want, and automatically
it will bring it up and down.
And a Managed
Instance Group also
does other things, like
rolling updates and more
than what I'm just telling you.
But for this demo, we are
only using those APIs.
So Managed Instance
Group is what
we are using to actually
implement our autoscaler.
So our autoscaler, I can
tell you more now about that
while we wait for
these to come up.
Well, the deployment has
finished successfully now.
You see that all of this is up.
If you go and look at your
VMs, you see them all here.
What's happening
now inside the VMs,
a startup script is running,
which is installing HTCondor.
So let me tell you a bit
more about the autoscaler
while we wait for
this to install.
It takes about a
couple of minutes.
And this is also a
measure of how long
you have to wait when you
bring up new resources.
So you autoscale up,
you submit more jobs,
you autoscale resources up.
In a couple of minutes, they
are available to run your jobs.
So how do you scale them up?
You can go back to the same
page as we were before.
There is a directory
called autoscaler.
If you click here,
there is a bunch
of instructions on how to set
this up so you can do that
yourself.
I'll show you how to do it.
What we are doing, we
have a Python software
that is called autoscaler,
not surprisingly.
We just accept a whole bunch of
different arguments documented
here.
What we want to do, we
want to go on a node--
in this case, we'll
use the Submit node--
and install the
software there, and then
call the autoscaler with the
appropriate parameters here.
So let's go through
the deployment.
Let's see if it has
finished, and then I'll
show you how to
install the autoscaler.
So to go to the Submit node,
you can click on the SSH button.
I'll bring up another
one in case I need it.
So what's happening
now, the system
is transferring
keys to the machines
so that then I can actually log
into the machines using SSH.
So this is the terminal.
Let me make it a bit bigger.
So what you see here is that
we have no jobs currently
on the system, nothing
is in the queue,
and that some nodes
are starting to become
available to report to it.
So what I want to do--
in principle, if I submit
jobs, these resources
will be able to run
the jobs for us.
What I want to show you now is
how to install the autoscaler.
So first, I need Git.
Let me install Git.
All right, and now the
directory that you want
is in the same repo
that I showed before.
So you git clone this.
OK, this is the same
direct repository
that I have installed in
my Cloud Shell before.
Now let's go to the autoscaler.
You want to run this program.
And what it will do, since
there is no job in the queue
and there are resources
available to run jobs,
if I ran the autoscaler
now, it will say, well,
I don't need all
these resources,
let me turn them off.
So let me cut and paste
this command here.
This is the one
that I did not want.
I opened in case I needed it.
I don't think I need it.
All right, and that's it.
The project name, as I said
before, is htcondor-demo.
And all the other
parameters are fine.
Now I'm using Verbosity 1.
What happens is
that the system will
see that there are more
machines than jobs,
and it will try to
bring them down.
Now, one thing that we can
do, we can submit more jobs.
I have some example jobs here--
applications.
This is a simple
piece of SQL that
calculates the first
n prime numbers,
just as a way to use
CPU and waste it.
I'm going to show you
the Condor Submit file.
This is the Condor Submit
file that specifies
how to run the program.
So the executable is prime.
Yeah, let's calculate the
first 400,000 prime numbers.
We don't have
anything better to do.
And so it lets me
run 12 of those.
All right, so I can submit it.
All right, so I have
no resources now,
but I have 12 idle jobs.
So let me run the resources
with the autoscaler.
Let me scale them up.
All right, so what's happening
is that I'm running--
I have 12 jobs
idle in the queue.
I need to bring
up three resources
to actually run these.
And so what's
happened is that there
are more resources that
are being brought up
because I need to run them.
All right, very good.
Rather than waiting until
all of this is brought up,
two minutes, et cetera, let me
summarize what I've told you.
So we have deployed
an HTCondor system
in about 10 to 12
minutes in GCP.
I showed you where
to get the software.
You have to Google "GitHub
GCP HTCondor," unsurprisingly.
You find the Google Deployment
Manager scripts there.
You can go to your Cloud Shell
and git clone that repository.
If you go into the
HTCondor context,
you can edit the parameters
of your Condor cluster,
and then launch the
Deployment Manager so that you
get your resources up here.
Once you have your
resources up, you
can use the cluster that way.
Or if you want to autoscale it
up and down, like we recommend,
then you can go to
one of the nodes.
The Submit node is a good one.
And then you git
clone the same repo.
And then you can put the
autoscaler in an automated
execution fashion.
Typically, we recommend
to put that as a cron job.
Maybe every five minutes you
can check, or every two minutes,
depending on your requirements.
And automatically, that will
bring up and down the resources
as you need.
And with this, I finish my demo.
[TITLE MUSIC PLAYING]